股市裡有一種
強勢上漲的訊號
幾乎就是送分題
它叫做
跳空缺口
當你還在看
K 線形態的時候
很多高手
早就在默默地關注
這個更強
也更直接的訊號
但你一定要注意
跳空缺口雖然強
卻也是最容易
踩到陷阱的地方
四種最常見的缺口裡
只有一種
是真正可以出手的
買進訊號
接下來5分鐘
我教你怎麼篩選出
真正代表
股價即將大漲的缺口
只要把今天的影片看完
搞懂今天的內容
就能大幅提升
你的投資獲利
我是小王子
20年資深交易員
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
用最簡單的方式來說
所謂的缺口
就是兩根 K 棒之間
出現一塊
沒有 K 棒經過的空白
為什麼會出現這種狀況
首先要搞懂
什麼是 K 棒
K 棒就是把
某一段時間的股價變化
畫成一根圖形
比如說日 K 線
一根 K 棒代表一天
它會告訴你四件事
一開始的開盤價
最後一筆成交的
收盤價
以及當天的最高價
跟最低價
收盤價
比開盤價還要高
我們叫紅 K 棒
代表買方比較有優勢
收盤價
比開盤價還要低
我們叫做黑 K 棒
代表賣方比較有優勢
如果今天收盤後
出現了重大消息
或是一些
有龐大資金的主力
故意拉抬
或是壓低股價
隔天一早
股價就很容易
出現劇烈的變化
舉例來說
一檔股票
今天的收盤價
是100塊
結果收盤之後
晚上突然出現好消息
隔天一開盤
大家都搶著要買
100塊
根本買不到
第一筆成交價
就來到104塊
接下來最高價106塊
最低價103塊
你就會發現
這兩根 K 棒之間
有一段
完全沒有去碰到的地方
也就是100塊
到103塊之間
因為沒有人
在這個價格成交
所以沒有 K 線經過
這塊空白就叫做缺口
如果往上漲形成缺口
叫做向上跳空
反過來也一樣
如果大家
都搶著要賣掉
成交價格
都比昨天的最低價
還要低
因為大幅下跌
中間形成的空白
也叫做向下跳空
所以我們可以知道
缺口代表
買方或賣方
有一股非常強的力量
推動股價
上漲或下跌
而且缺口越大
代表這股力量越強
但出現缺口
只代表今天的力量很強
沒辦法保證接下來
還會繼續
上漲或下跌
比如這張圖
這裡出現了
向上的跳空
缺口還非常的大
但跳空後的隔天
股價反而下跌了
這是因為
缺口有不同的種類
代表的訊號
也差非常多
有些缺口
代表強烈的上漲訊號
有些只是
無效的雜訊
有些反而告訴你
接下來
股價即將反轉
所以接下來
我要教你怎麼找出
真正能代表
上漲訊號的缺口
我們可以把缺口
分為四種
第一種普通缺口
跟它的名字一樣
它就是只是一個缺口
沒有判斷趨勢的功能
屬於要過濾掉的雜訊
第二種突破缺口
這是最重要的缺口
它代表股價
從這個位置開始
要進入一段
上漲或下跌
也是最好的進場時機
第三種持續缺口
在上漲或下跌的趨勢裡
出現持續的缺口
代表接下來
這個趨勢還會持續
最後一種竭盡缺口
這個訊號出現代表
股價已經
漲不動或跌不動
力氣已經用完了
很快就會迎來反轉
接下來
重點中的重點來了
缺口獲利的關鍵
就在於
如果你今天
看到一個缺口
到底要怎麼分辨
它是哪一種
第一步
先觀察股價的趨勢
我們可以看這條
20日均線
均線的意思很簡單
就是把
過去一段時間的收盤價
平均起來
畫成一條線
20日均線
差不多就是
過去20個交易日
大家買進的平均成本
如果股價
最近一段時間
幾乎都在
這條均線的上方
代表現在是
上漲趨勢
如果股價
都在均線的下方
代表目前是
下跌的趨勢
如果股價
沒有明確站在
均線的上方或下方
而是在一個
固定的範圍內
上上下下
這個叫做盤整趨勢
當股價趨勢很明顯
就會產生
持續缺口
或是竭盡缺口
這兩種缺口
我們等下再來討論
對新手來說
最重要的是
先學會區分
盤整趨勢裡面出現的
普通缺口
跟突破缺口
因為一個是無效訊號
要過濾掉
不用理它
另外一個則是
強烈的漲跌訊號
要趕快出手
要區分這兩種缺口
關鍵就在於
支撐跟壓力
當股票有個
不容易再漲高的價格
這個價格叫做壓力
就像房子的天花板
你再怎麼用力跳
也很難突破它
當股價有個
不容易再跌到更低的價格
這個價格
就叫做支撐
就像房子的地板
你在上面跑來跑去
也不會跌下去
支撐跟壓力就是
股價盤整時
會在一個範圍之內
來來回回的原因
我們可以把
股價最近的一段時間
上漲之後
反轉下跌的點
用一條線連接起來
這條線
就是壓力線
反過來
把下跌之後
反轉上漲的點連起來
叫做支撐線
判斷缺口有沒有效
關鍵就在於
這兩條線
如果股價
在盤整趨勢裡出現缺口
但第二根 K 棒
沒有明顯的突破壓力
或是跌破支撐
這個缺口
就是普通的缺口
屬於無效的訊號
像這張圖
這兩個缺口
都還在支撐線
跟壓力線裡面
所以不管是
向上跳空
還是向下跳空
都無法產生持續上漲
或持續下跌的力量
但如果在盤整趨勢裡
出現缺口
而且第二根的K線收盤價
明顯突破壓力
這種缺口
就是突破缺口
代表接下來
會有一波很強的上漲
原本的缺口
就會變成
新的股價支撐
反過來也一樣
如果缺口
向下跳空跌破支撐
也會迎來一波
很強的下跌
原本的缺口
則會變成新的壓力
突破缺口產生之後
股價會形成
明確的趨勢
這裡就會進入到
第二個階段
在明確的趨勢裡
如果出現缺口
可能是
確認趨勢繼續進行的
持續缺口
也可能是
代表反轉的竭盡缺口
這兩種缺口要怎麼分
就要講到另外一個
非常重要的概念
缺口回補
缺口出現之後
有一定的機率
K棒會回到
缺口的位置
如果整個缺口
都被反向的K棒關起來
也就是說
股票的收盤價
完全填補了缺口
像這樣
代表股價
可能要迎來反轉
不過這裡
有一個小細節要注意
判斷缺口
有沒有回補
要看的是收盤價
很多時候
你看起來
好像缺口
回補起來了
但實際上
它只是假回補
比如這張圖
它的跳空缺口
在這個位置
雖然看起來
K 棒填補了整個缺口
但實際上
你看到紅K的收盤價在上面
所以這裡並沒有把缺口填補
不算是回補
你之所以要搞懂回補
是因為
在上漲或下跌的趨勢裡
你看到的缺口
到底是持續缺口
還是竭盡缺口
最直接的分辨方法
就是看缺口
有沒有在三日內回補
如果缺口在上漲趨勢裡
三根 K 棒之內
缺口都沒有回補
就可能是持續的缺口
接下來
還會持續地上漲
但如果缺口
很快的就被補起來
這個就是
即將反轉的訊號
可以準備賣出
以上兩種
分辨缺口的方法
我現在
幫你把重點整理好了
你可以先暫停截圖
在進入實戰教學之前
我再補充一個
會讓缺口失效的
例外狀況
除權息的缺口
有些股票
每年都會把股息或股利
發給股東
這個叫除權息
你可以理解成
公司分紅給你
但是公司
把錢發給你之後
隔天的股價
也會相對應地下跌
所以看起來
就會有一個明顯的缺口
但這個缺口
並不是因為
買賣雙方的力量產生的
所以是無效的訊號
要排除這些訊號
也非常簡單
你只要找到
看盤軟體上的
還原按鈕
點一下
這種缺口
就會自己補起來
接下來
我們進入實戰環節
我們看到
這一張華容的走勢圖
在抓上漲之前
第一步
一定是先找到
盤整的趨勢
然後畫出
支撐跟壓力的線
畫好之後
就會看得很清楚
像這裡的缺口
它沒有突破壓力
也沒有跌破支撐
所以這就是
普通的缺口
屬於無效訊號
真正值得注意的
是這裡的缺口
你可以看到
向上跳空的
這根 K 棒
明顯地突破壓力線
上漲力道很強
我們就可以在
隔天開盤買進
買進之後
股價也確實開始上漲
這個時候趨勢
已經轉為上漲
觀察重點
就要改成
缺口有沒有回補
像這裡兩個位置
出現缺口之後
三根 K 棒之內
都沒有回補
我們就可以判斷
這波的漲勢還會持續
最關鍵的是
這個缺口
這個缺口很小
代表上漲的力道
已經沒有
前面這麼強了
而且往後數
一二三
第三根 K 棒的收盤價
完全回補了缺口
把缺口關起來了
代表趨勢
可能要開始反轉
這個時候
就可以在隔天賣出
避開後面
這一段的大跌
整個流程走下來
獲利非常可觀
足足有126%
這就是跳空缺口
厲害的地方
前面幾個月股價
可能都沒有什麼變化
但只要抓到
這一段的上漲
就能在短時間內
獲得很高的收益
好
到這裡
你應該已經看懂
股價的缺口
要怎麼使用
接下來
只要再學會
兩個加分項
就能大幅提升你的獲利
第一個加分項
要怎麼從
台股2300多檔股票裡
每天只花5分鐘
找出有機會出現
突破缺口的股票
第二個加分項是
除了一般的缺口之外
其實還有一種
更進階的缺口形態
叫做島狀反轉
它代表股價
將會出現
非常強烈的反轉
可以讓你
賺到大段的漲幅
或是避開
大段的下跌
這兩個加分項
只靠今天這支影片
很難講清楚
所以我會把
快速選股的方法
島狀反轉的實際案例
跟具體的操作內容
都放在我的
免費線上直播講座裡
講座流程
除了會教你
怎麼使用
免費的線上工具
設定我獨家的選股條件
還會跟你分享
除了島狀反轉之外
其他我常用的
股票大漲的訊號
以及從買進到停損、停利的
實際買賣流程
點擊下方資訊欄連結
就可以報名
免費的線上講座
已經有超過百位投資人
用了這些方法之後
投資績效突飛猛進
因為講座是免費的
所以名額有限
如果點擊連結點進去
沒有看到場次
代表已經額滿了
如果這支影片
對你有幫助
記得幫我按讚一下
有什麼想聽的
也可以在下面
留言告訴我
我是小王子
我們下次見